[Music]
hey babe
hey babe hey babe
let me see if i can read your mind or
you can go off
small cues of my face and eyes and i go
up small cues yours to see if we can say
it at the exact same time
without counting down okay
hey babe whoa nice
nailed just two grown men all right
just trying to say worries at the same
time that's what it is we did it
so we're going to start off the show
today with obviously the question that's
been on many people's minds as of late
because of what's been happening in the
news
are there any homosexual animals that's
correct yeah yeah
and there's been articles written about
it you find anything on the internet
yeah jamie foxx used to do a bit
on one of the specials where he said
someone had to do this giraffes are gay
okay which because they do walk around
and look kind of giraffes kind of prance
around yeah they do yeah so i guess if
it was going to be a gay animal it's
giraffes
but i believe there is quite a lot
there's a lot of homosexuality through
the animal
kingdom oh yeah so are we saying
something that's common knowledge like
are there people like of course animals
well 10 animal species that show how
being gay is is
is natural so necking giraffes
okay uh sheeps are gay uh
studies suggest that up to eight percent
of males and flocks of sheep prefer
other males
even when fertile females are around
however this only occurs among domestic
sheep well of course i mean a sheep
looks at other animals and sees it
they're gay and of course the sheep
becomes gay yeah
and yes studies have found that
homosexual sheep have different brain
structures than their heterosexual
counterparts and release less sex
hormones sheeps don't have a mind of
their own so they're going to follow
whatever other gay animals that are
they're friends with let's see what
other animals obviously dolphins
everyone knows dolphins are gay
bottlenose dolphins of course that's the
layup they
bottle yeah let's go four who else are
gay
lions are gay interesting of them in the
act
homosexuality is common among lions two
to four males often form what is known
as a coalition
where they work together jesus a
coalition there's names for it
a gay coalition a gay lion gathering i'm
chrissy coalitions
where they work together and get gay
mounting bisons
wow bisons are getting ready to be
honest if i'm a bison right and i'm like
questioning you know if i i'm
questioning my my my
my my sexuality and where i'm going to
go
i might think twice i might come out
later than i would have
because if i admit it that means a bison
well excuse me just hey babes just hey
baby yeah about
but it's interesting because the reason
why scientists believe
that there's such a con homosexuality so
common in the bison community is
actually because
female bisons only mate with male bisons
once a year so the female bisons are not
necessarily giving up the bison
keeping it close to the rest just hey
baby yes five minutes you're going here
we're good yeah we have to make sure
that yeah
uh uh mccarthy mccarthy's right
both female and male macaws m
m-a-c-a-q-u-e-s apostrophe
mc mcquakes can you go to the uh
pronunciation
how do we pronounce my quakes
[Laughter]
quake mcquake's pronunciation how do we
let's hear it because macaque
it sounds like it's saying macaque
macaque
the cox what do you want mccox
well you're damn right they're gay
they're like how do we let them know if
they're wondering if we're gay
like just please refer to us all as
macaques would you like to touch
macaques
yeah um albatross are gay
an interesting albatross also the
what wait we are gonna put this five
minutes till the back of you
we're saying hey babe that word too
we need let's talk about cartoons
sex craze bonobos
[Laughter]
oh my god like that is a full-on that is
crazy they're doing missionary
style and here's why it's interesting
bonobos
or bonibos i think it's i always thought
it was bonobos but also
uh that's where it gets slacks but
this is a brick and mortar it's a retail
store yeah they sell clothing well and
it's also a gay uh animal
it's a sex it says it's a sex crack
craze
bonobos are considered the closest
living relative to humans and are known
for seeking sexual pleasure okay
they copulate frequently including with
the same sex so they have sex all day
every day
they're having wild sex but it's to they
do it for pleasure but also to bond with
each other climb the social ladder and
reduce tension
so that's so the interesting thing about
about homosexuality
is is is bo that happens in humans too
there's
wait hold on hold on hold on let's go
ahead read it
it's a wild statistic the statistic
we're reading
a fifth of all swan couples are gay
that's why here i am roaming the earth
wondering if animals are gay in general
you know how many swans there are yeah
how many a fifth of all
how many swans are there how many swans
because i want to know right now
because this could also be educational
like there's one fifth or twenty percent
twenty percent how many swans are there
in the world they're seven species
are they endangered it says how many
swans are left i'm saving the swans
right here if they're the
gayest animal on earth we need to say
well maybe that might be why they get
becoming a state because they can't
procreate
yes maybe yes uh
indicates they are currently between 1.5
and 1.6 million swans in the world
that's it so if there's a million if
that doesn't sound like a lot to me it
doesn't sound like in the world
so we're thinking about 20 250 thousand
give or take
there was 1.5 million people on planet
earth 1.5 million people
right on planet earth right it'd be like
jeez i wonder when i'm going to cross
paths with another human
like that's not a lot right so when you
see a swan
you're seeing yeah that feels rare to me
but then 20 percent right 20 so
300 000 gay swans 300
000 gay swans wow interesting
keep close walruses
male walrus they eat they reach sexual
maturity at the age of four
uh wow that's it keep them away from
chris hanson
no but not for nothing they are almost
until they reach their sexual maturity
of force out they are exclusively gay
what it says they're exclusively gay
until they reach the sexual maturity at
the age of four
are most people walking around with this
information no
i we didn't know if they were gay
animals at all it turns out hello
hello stupids there's so many animals is
it me too or
are most of the gay animals burly and
big and like and they aren't yeah most
of the gay animals are what the gay
community would refer to as bears but
notice bears didn't make the list by the
way in the gay community i would say
you're a bear
i probably am i was a twink but i've put
on more weight now
if i grew my hair and i'd also be a bear
i don't know what i'd be considered but
you are a bear
make no no make no mistake but i
recently read a new term
okay it's not bare and it wasn't twinkie
and i don't remember what it was but it
was another term what are the gay what
can we get common gay terms um
pimp is just writing bleep out a bunch
yeah yeah
common common gay uh common gay terms or
lgbt slang um like
bear yeah all right yeah what do we got
a textbook definition and you were just
like you know you're a
baron i'm like i am a bear yeah just am
i just an obese hairy man
yeah oh but here we go through an image
of rugged masculinity though here's what
i am not a bear
but here's what a gay hairy man that
does not project any masculinity and
here's what i am
i'm a big hairless man example of bear
without x i'm a big guy and i'm known as
a manatee
the humanity on
dude i'd rather grow your beard out and
not be called a manatee a manatee is
mostly just blubber right i can't grow
i can't grow hair on my legs or my chest
and i grow very
people
same with me and i tell them i do not
shave my legs
my dad let me talk into the mic my dad
legs well since i'm born like since i'm
little bald
has all his hair didn't go grain till
his late 60s no hair on his legs my
father take it i swim faster so
my exactly my father exactly could never
grow a full beard
could never grow could never barely grow
facial never had chester never had hair
on his legs
still to this day 74 years old not it's
not a
line of gray hair i guess it's something
like it just just
yeah decide whether you want that
because you have good hair thank you you
have really good hair buddy no you
totally i'm not just saying that to you
as
a bear or anything like that no dude i'm
a manatee you have
phenomenal i told you about this last
episode you have great hair
i think um by the way they're saying now
that coronavirus is
uh um uh baldness is another uh is
another symptom of corona so
literally anything that could anything
anything anything that's ever happening
in your life covered caused it yeah
um but let me ask you a question so we
saw a lot of uh
wild animals that they said were gay but
what about like a gay pet like
like would you know if you're it i mean
is it just is it just a matter of if
your dog
is male and then attempts to you know
have sex with a with a with another male
dog
is that just the only tell singular
telltale you said your dog is gay why do
you think your dog's gay
um i don't know he just instead of meat
he likes more like vegetables
that's why he thinks he's gay
metrosexual yeah yeah health
consciousness he's healthy
we just asked pimp that why he thinks
he's gay his dog is gay and he said
he doesn't like meat he prefers
vegetables which
and also he got mounted by the
neighborhood like stray
and he likes it yeah but okay he got
mounted
yeah he didn't mount no no no but he
liked it he stayed the course he was
happy
really he just wants vegetables and and
the neighborhoods and the neighborhoods
tray
yeah yeah i think i think um
yeah it's interesting take much to make
it man what's your dog's name uh
phantom gay name phantom wow
it's a gay name that could be it could
be both i yeah
i don't know i i tell you because you
know i've talked about this podcast the
one dog i had cruella i killed her
by accident and then my other dog larry
never really came out of the house he
had an anxiety condition
so i don't i do think though if larry
would have come out of the house well i
believe he was gay
really i believe my dog right now larry
is in the gay part of
animal heaven it's got to be a spectrum
just like us right
yes dude what about ethnicities
like if if a dog is born over in like
well i know there's english bulldogs and
anything like other
other but like what do you think about
it
like are are dogs like from like
overseas
the exact same as the dogs here or is
there literally like
like a separation like how humans have
like different
you know what i mean like like like i
know that we we have
dogs that have were created not like
produced in other countries here what do
they made them and what do you call it
well like a like a breed
when they breed them like we have like
you're asking me like is a british ball
dog like do they act british
like do they have do they have teeth if
they if they're not from here would they
would there be a chance that they would
exhibit other traits the
dogs here don't like do they have habits
or uh
hang-ups or or anything any kind of
behavioral pattern
from a dog overseas would we be able to
indicate that
by their behaviors i don't i'm going to
say cultural differences
it's the same [ __ ] right they just feed
them walk them and they poop
i i don't think but then again i don't
know like does it does a british bulldog
in britain walk a little bit more prim
and proper than
an american bulldog do dogs from
different countries have different
personalities
no not dramatically in this day and age
most well-bred purebreds
have at least one ancestor from another
country uh temperaments are more based
on breed and breeding
than geographic location okay
interesting
you know and it there's dogs are
fascinating
things like for like in every dog
because of the breeds have something
different like my dog larry who passed
away was a dachshund
and many doctrines they have this thing
that happens to where their anal glands
fill up with fluid and they can't it
gets to a point where they fill up so
much
that i would have to put on a glove
chocolate lab labs too because
my buddy casey just did it with his dog
i would have to pop their anal glands
and it
i mean the smell let me tell you
something i can't imagine the smell
i can't believe well that's the gay dog
right there and that's and that's
another gay dog right the alaskan
gay gay gay yeah what about the one up
top who's that one
let me find him um oh yeah some dogs
look like they
are a little bit more just fun and
effective right uh not that
you know like that they just if if there
was going to be a gay dog
no but let let me just interject quick
being effeminate as a man
is more fun than not when i it is so
much when i'm getting like this and
having fun and being like hey girl
what's up i'm having the [ __ ] time of
my life and
that's what i think gay men have figured
out is that we could do this all the
time
yeah and then it's not even like we're
putting it on it's almost like
it's almost like we're just like let's
just do it until let's just do it
forever from now on like when i start
talking like this and doing like this
and moving my hands
it's very difficult to just stop i know
like
i kind of just having fun right now and
start doing this
and then it's not like i can just be
like okay let me like it literally like
takes
a little while i totally understand i'll
tell you another thing and this happens
with various people and various uh you
know
sexualities and we'll have but when i'm
around a gay person
right my my inner gay comes out even
more
oh me too i'll just you know like i'm
just like i am a little bit like when
i'm with like the way that we joke
around
he just subconsciously we're very much
more like
that i swear to god you put you put like
is sal
in google and the first thing that's
always good same with me i'm not i'm
literally not but
but but what do you want me to tell you
man almost every single time
it's just fun to be a little bit more
free like clockwork
now she just knows when i go home after
doing this podcast
my girlfriend will say because of the
way i'm acting she'll be like did you do
the podcast with sal today she just
knows
yeah because i'm just coming in like hi
let's order some ottomans i come
skipping in
i literally i'm just ready to get gay oh
i
love it yeah i just want to watch real
housewives i put my feet up i'm doing
mani petty's i know yeah i know
my love my daughter i have a daughter a
five-year-old daughter she loves when i
act gay she yeah
she because she's like you're so i put
on you know i'll dress up i'll go crazy
she loves it she gets the time realized
she puts makeup on me she can't if i'm
like if i'm literally to my daughter
like what would be your ideal friday
night with daddy i guarantee you like
when he sits down and lets me put my
makeup on him yeah and we watch
our disney movies yeah those are like
the best nights we've ever read
we're watching moana and she's putting
eyeliner on me my daughter is legit
she's in heaven
she can't guess who else is in heaven me
you me
yes yes i love it i know i love it and
it's why i have a single photo
really boiled down to it though if it
really boiled down to it
[Music]
you you wouldn't be able to have a gay
experience if
it boiled down to i could say this i
could say this
i think there is a uh
i would say i could absolutely
find myself in time i'm talking about
maybe in my 50s
in time i'm not saying to have sexual
intercourse with a man right
but i could find myself if i have more
and more
experiences where things just don't work
out work out with the woman just say
hey babe i'm going i'm going the guys
and i'm just going to go out and have go
on dates with men but not have sex with
them but go on dates and
because i find men interesting and i
like to talk to them and i find women
interesting of course
but i find myself getting fascinated
sometimes with men
yeah yeah is that gay my gay friends are
just
they're just terrific to hang out with
they always boost my spirits immediately
they're like a
they're like this beacon of positivity
all the time i've been i have some gay
friends that are not like that
but for the most part uh love a good gay
love a good kid i literally feel like
our good friend and good friend of the
show matteo lane who's a good friend of
mine
been in my house so many times i
genuinely feel like if i picked him up
and threw him
he would land in a triple axel like i
feel like if i threw him
he would just triple axel and land
yeah and i would just hold up a 10. yeah
you don't get gayer than matteo
and the thing is with a guy like mateo
is he's he's
a no doubt about it gay he's a d1g as we
call it a day one game
this was this was something that you're
there was it's it was a
100 chance of being gay yeah in the womb
in utero gay like you can't imagine yeah
yeah he came
like he was born and he was like you'll
be swell
yeah it will be great yeah i had the
whole world on a plane
yeah and they were like believe it or
not it's a boy it's a boy as soon as he
came out he wrapped the umbilical cord
around his neck like a scarf
he just came out and he was like yeah
like
google them things yeah opera but then
you're so physically fit but it's
interesting though because what
gay is because you have a person like
matteo lane good friend of the show game
but then you also have the great tim
dillon yes also gay would never know
very different gay very difficult you
can't be more heterous we're
heterosexuals you just
you're heterosexual or not but the gay
spectrum is a beautiful thing
doesn't necessarily uh you know speak uh
uh no but his fans know he's scared
we're not we're not outing
no no not out but my
but it is funny what tim has written on
his chest and one of his pictures go
google it
it's hilarious i will say i knew tim for
a while before i
found out he was gay right when i found
out i was like wow i would have
never guessed that yeah no tim tim is
one of those guys yeah so it's just a
gay spectrum you never know but i mean
by the way by the way just i mean just
to say i mean who's funnier than tim
dillon i mean i mean
i mean tim dillon
yeah timmy's great so so yeah so so ken
you know again with this podcast we had
no intention of talking about animals
being gay
we just kind of started talking about it
so you know
let me ask you this yeah sometimes i
make choices
and i'm like this isn't helping uh you
know
people's perception of my sexuality now
i recently bought an outfit
okay you ever buy an outfit that you
think might look good in the store okay
and you're like or
even in the store you're like this is
either i was gonna say fierce but
right this is either an amazing outfit
or it's really ugly
okay and i'm either gonna put it on and
it's going to respond to me
and people will love it or i'm going to
put it on and it's going to be terrible
you ever buy clothes and be like i don't
know if this is ugly or amazing right
i bought an outfit recently right and
i've it was like two years like a year
or two ago and i've never worn it yet
because as i got home i'm like i
appreciate everything
this outfit brings to the table right
it's fun it's
funny it's colorful and it is it's i've
never seen anything like it
but if i put this on i am going to look
like an
aging gay gumball an agent queen
yes do a favor can you in if i
got up and put this outfit on and walked
back out can we edit it so people aren't
waiting for me to change
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna put an
outfit on for you put it on
i'm gonna you're gonna see it for the
first time when i walk back out of the
room perfect is that okay
i love it okay all right all right yo
i'm gonna start talking
no i'm to say i have my eyes closed and
i want the fr let me know when we're
ready to go
okay i have my eyes closed right now
because i genuinely want to be surprised
by the first time that sal comes out in
this outfit
and sal you tell me what you're already
settled and i will open my eyes and take
a look
go ahead walk in this is sal's outfit
that he said he doesn't know if you
look like an aging gumball and if is
this outfit gay
i have my eyes closed i am not looking i
will look when he sits down in his
comfortable position
and is ready to speak and just let me
know when i can open my eyes and take a
look
i mean not only do you look gay
yeah get to the mic not only does it
first of all i think it's awesome yeah
but it looks
gay and it also looks like you have
special needs
[Laughter]
it looks like you're the rare combo of a
special needs gay man
okay i was in a store it was like it was
a really nice streetwear store
and this is bold but it's got wrestlers
on it and it's a summertime
sweat outfit and it's shorts and you
know it's cut on the bottom and it's got
your wrestling
you know it's got everybody from you
could see
yeah it's got everybody warrior yeah
bret hart
and i'm like this is an amazing matching
outfit i'm gonna be the hit of a party
in this thing
yeah roll up it looks comfortable too
it's got you know
it's like this local brand from brooklyn
and i mind you look tank's still on
right but actually that's a little
secret little life hack for you
i don't take tags off my clothes i think
we talked about this never uh
i i usually what do you mean yeah i
don't take takes over my cause i usually
pull the tag off my clothes
after about three months yeah
what's the reason uh because i uh don't
want to have buyer's remorse and i want
to make sure that i really
am um i really am okay with with the
garment
and i want the option to so what i do
usually is i i do have the gun
where i i could re re put like the tags
back on yeah that's how you
okay so that i could always bring
something so you'll wash clothes with
the tags on
no usually it's like um a jacket or a
sweatshirt or a hoodie
but where do you hunt do you so you just
hide pants that thing that's like
sewn into the the back of it on because
you know you could always put it back on
what you got me like a loose hanging tag
like this especially if it's in the
inside of a shirt just put on the inside
i just put it on the inside
so if we go downstairs in my closet
right now you will see dozens of things
so you're someone who literally who
literally
will have to sometimes stop the podcast
to readjust the corner of a pillow
but can walk around all day with the tag
on your back that's correct
yes you know i just that's insane no but
i just want to be like they're not going
to get me
yeah you know you know what if i wear
this here twice and all of a sudden it
starts to fray
or pill or oh but how do you know
they'll take it back what if i don't
wear it for a while and i put it on it's
snug
or if i buy it it's snug and i'm hoping
to lose weight and i don't then i can't
use it or what if you buy it what if you
buy and you accidentally drop some
saratoga peanut butter on it
maybe and it's that's a family-run
business and not a sponsor there's a lot
of flavors
and hopefully they make a flavor with us
one day yeah um
it's interesting by the way i i you know
i came out obviously he was joking
around i actually
like that and be would be willing to say
if you don't want it i'll take it is
that right
hundred percent i take it i take that
right now really i take it
oh see i and you know what it is over
the summer i had the outfit
and uh i was always like i'm gonna i'm
gonna wear this to an event this summer
a barbecue a friend's house
and every time i put it on i would take
it right back off because i said
who do i think i am to wear that i can't
pull this off
i can't pull this off and that's the
first sign that you can't that's because
if you don't believe it
yeah you're not gonna do it you can't
let this where you right now this is
wearing me
right i have to wear it do you remember
do you remember i think this was
last year when we went into we were
performing and you you and i were
working together in cleveland
and i went into that thrift store or or
cool one-off store in cleveland and i
bought that sweatshirt that had all
different wrappers on it
and different colors and all that 100
the same scenario
i would put i put it on two or three
times got to the front door walked right
back in took it off put something else
on i know
i know what you're talking about you
have to be kind of a bold [ __ ] yeah
to walk out with stuff like that yeah
this is again i
i bought this in the same type of store
it was one of those fashion one-off
fashion stores uh shout out to them uh
yeah shout out that store in cleveland i
it took about an hour and a half for
them to package the sweatshirt
do you remember that nice guy but you
bought
one sweatshirt it took 40 minutes but do
you remember also they were
closed but then they let us come in yeah
and they were they were filming a video
or something
something crazy yeah but then also there
was three products for sale
the hoodie was one of them yeah the
hoodie was one of them and then you
would think there's only three products
for sale you're like i'll take this
and the guy went in the back and then it
was 40 minutes for him to come out and
process it
i couldn't i yeah i remember that very
well but that but that's the
that's the the only thing that i can
remember
about about uh uh anything that was
bolded out but but again
i look like uh like uh like like uh
a flamboyant pepto-bismol no i said i i
do look like
you know like this isn't like this isn't
gonna help me
well this is what this isn't going to
help me will clarify
what my preferences are listen when the
world reopens and you know wrestlemania
or summerslam is at barclay center in
brooklyn
i mean what what's the other option what
is the other you already wore the cool
wrestling jacket when you did yes
so you already wore certain i mean you
have to do that i got to do it so you
know
i'm breaking it here first now i got to
pull the tags off of it
yeah because they'll never believe me
now they'll never believe you now
yeah yeah let me let me also explain
something i don't i don't
scam anyone no the opposite is scamming
i i don't i won't wear it like 20 times
and then return it yeah
usually i wear it a couple times and
then if i like it i pull the tail but i
never prematurely pulled the tag off
you're an
honest honest shopper an honest buyer
and
and you've given me some of the best
products i've ever had in my life almost
to the point where
i kind of get paralyzed with thinking
about what i can get you for christmas
because i just know your gift will be
better and more thoughtful and i really
i try to meditate i drink a whole bunch
of tea i
i have a seance i really try to think
about what i could get
sal's sal and his family for christmas
and i never the answer is you don't have
to give me anything that's the answer i
know but i gotta get you but i get you
something
the truth is what normally happens is
because i just give up and i get you a
gift card
you don't have to do that don't worry
about it don't stress anything but as
guys what's a better gift than a gift
card not much but i will tell you and i
don't know if this is an indication of
sexual preference
right but the way i shop for christmas
is i just
i'm 24 7 shopping for christmas 365.
right
no no joke it could be it could be march
and i see something i go oh they'll like
that and i either purchase it and store
it
or i have i have a note in my phone
that's like christmas gifts for when it
comes i'm always compiling the list so
that one
christmas finally creeps up on us which
it always does because life gets in the
way
right you uh then go and you're like oh
what am i gonna get this was and i've
been documenting it all year and then
like
you remembered when i go i remember i
put it right down i
love getting a good gift for someone a
good good gift for someone and i got to
be honest with you
just because i know you know what it is
you are wearing the same socks as
another episode we did about aliens you
have the same socks on
is that going to be okay or do we have
to not do the podcast ever again yeah i
i i i just don't want people to get
confused see the thumbnail
see the socks are the same and choose
not to click right what you should be
doing is sharing
everything subscribing to the youtube
channel no pressure network
you should be you know you know
following us and following us
don't see don't see the socks and run
away don't do that and hey
pod of course on all social media
platforms
hey i'm here with uh comedian christa
stefano and the word on the street is
you've been getting erection after
erection like it's nobody's business
yeah what's your secret i've been
getting a lot of erections hi my name's
chris
yeah i've been getting a lot of
erections as you said
and a lot of people have asked me what
my secret is and the secret is bluetooth
specifically bluechew.com the promo code
hey babe all i did all i did was pay the
five dollar shipping when i put in the
promo code h-e-y-b-a-b-e
and they sent me the blue cheese for
free i took one i got an instant
erection
really and and and is it discreet
because nobody wants to really go make
an appointment and talk penis with
anyone
it was all online everything was online
it came in a package that was discreet
nobody knew my own family member my own
father who's also having erectile
dysfunction didn't know that i had the
blue chews
and i've been walking around with a
stiffy as the kids say for the past
three months
from bluechew.com promo code hey babe so
that's it you didn't have to speak penis
with
with anybody with anybody i didn't speak
about penis with anything i told the
physician
what was going on that i've been
suffering from a limp penis
they said we just have the thing for you
it's a blue chew yeah
so that's all you gotta do is promo code
hey babe it's made with the same
ingredients
fda give me all the business the it's
made with the same ingredients as viagra
and cialis it's
competitors it is made right here in the
usa because the last thing
i wanted was a non-patriotic penis my
penis stands up for the red white and
blue bluechew.com promo code hey babe
five dollars shipping the rest is free
there you go i'm coming to you live from
the brooklyn streets with christa
stefano comedian
with an erect penis
chris you know how you've been visiting
goodhelp.com
yeah for online counseling yeah there's
something that's going to beat that now
what is it it's betterhelp.com also i
don't know if good help is actually an
address oh but i know you've been trying
to type in good health
that's why i'm getting the results no no
you got to go to betterhelp.help.com
for professional online counseling it's
discreet it's affordable you can contact
someone within under 48 hours
it's worldwide there's a range of
experts available and all you got to do
is go to betterhelp.help
backslash hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e
and you will get 10 off your first month
please don't say anything yet
okay and if you've been thinking about
going and getting professional
counseling because let me tell you right
now
we're all cooped up and we're all having
a real hard time this year and things
are under our skin
and we got things to vent about and it's
always a good idea
to reach out for help if you think you
need it and where you're going to get
better help
then betterhelp.com slash hey babe 10
off your first month
yeah please i i don't really need you to
say anything for this
thank you guys for listening
betterhelp.com back slash hey babe ten
percent off first one
okay so remember the other day i told
you i said i'm sick and tired of going
to the grocery store i'm not doing any
more there's covert there's lines i
don't want to do any more yeah you were
screaming at me and i said can there be
at least one place that gives me
22 or more fresh recipes and ingredients
it was specific but i thought it was odd
but yeah you said that well i found it
hellofresh i went to hellofresh.com you
ready for what i did oh i know about
hello fresh you know that hellofresh
what would you do
i went to i couldn't believe what this
was was happening i go to hellofresh.com
on a whim i put in the promo code hey
babe 10.
just out of nowhere i said just try
something you know so i go hey babe 10
promo code they gave me 10 free meals
you paid for shipping i didn't pay for
shipping get out of here i checked my
credit card bill i called i said there's
been fraudulent activity there's
no nobody even charged me for shipping i
got 10 hello fresh meals in here by
using the promo code hey babe
who's the ceo of hellofresh crazy eddie
that's insane it's santa claus
what are even the options for the food i
did look it up okay there's there's carb
smart
okay local pescatarian vegetarian
everything you want
and it's basically uh they they package
fresh produce from from local farmers
from local farmers i mean what else do
you want
they're even following the trends here
yeah and you know what they do they
pre-package the portions and the
ingredients so you're not over buying
i saw that you ever go to these big box
stores and buy enough for a month and
then it goes
away you're spending too much on your
wallet it's too much waste for the
environment
i don't need it this is helping out i
don't need it at all and and and these
little packages they come and i cook
them i've learned finally learned how to
cook
i feel safe because getting delivered
right to my door and i'm telling you i'm
telling you i literally was sitting down
it was like
god himself was speaking to me or
herself or they self would speak to me
and they said do me a favor chris
go to hellofresh.com put in the promo
code
hey babe 10. and watch your dreams come
true
and they did i got 10 free meals
including free shipping that's a lot
that's a lot of meals if you eat three
meals a day that's like three meals
point one day worth of food for no
for no no cost no cost at all i don't
understand how
i don't understand the business model
that's not for us to decide it's not for
us go to hellofresh.com
hey babe10 use code hey babe10 for 10
free meals
including free shipping yeah america's
number one meal kit
all right i'm doing stand-up again
january 16th in the middle of a field in
pennsylvania royersford pennsylvania
heated tent
it's going to be great one show go to
christycomedy.com for tickets or
souljalls with an s.com for tickets
souljalls.com
january 16th royersford pennsylvania i'm
doing an hour
it's going to be chaotic it's going to
be wild why not come
it's there's heaters there they're going
to have beers bring your lawn chair
it's going to be great january 16th
doing a little stand up maybe i'll
facetime sell
i'll tell you i got caught up in a
little bit of a scam when i was younger
what happened so my cousin
who who will go unnamed uh used to go to
let's just call him you're an italian
from stanley let's just call him
giovanni giovan
g used to go to um i think it's very uh
innovative he used to go to like
marshalls
and like uh tj maxx and then he used to
buy
clothes at steep discounts okay
and return them to macy's wow
thousands of beans at a time how but
isn't that
it could you do that in in modern times
long time ago
because now with scanning and they would
know it's not from now so what happened
was
he was one of the first ones like
pioneer he was doing this in the wild
west he's
he's a pioneer he was really what is he
doing right he's not doing
anything that bad i mean what he's doing
is actually capitalism
that's correct there's no who said i
can't do that i agree but
you know they got wise okay so he was
doing it so much he was
he was making thousands up you buy like
a pair of you know whatever you want you
got you buy yourself a pair of guests
dungarees in tj maxx and cg for twenty
dollars for twenty dollars you bring
them back to
macy's for seventy dollars so you just
made 50. yeah and they what they
in the very beginning they used to give
him uh um
they used to give cash back in the
beginning can you believe
cash they switched it then they started
giving you credit back
and then what he used to do is use that
to buy better clothing and then he would
sell that clothing
on ebay and still net out with the money
but then
they started realizing that it was
happening a lot because they used to
take your name down
and so then they started saying you
could only return like three times
without a receipt
so then he would go ask all of our
friends and family members can i borrow
your license
and i get i would give him my license so
that when he went to the macy's for the
returns
and they asked for his id they wouldn't
flag him because and then it was my
return now this was a long time ago macy
don't look this up
and um and i got caught up in that and
that might be
where it was in my head to like be like
well i don't ever want to be called my
pants down no pun
but i want to keep the tag on and no
one's going to tell me what i could do
because i got the tag on
which is absurd it's absurd that if you
pull
a piece of cardboard this big off
they're like all bets are
off right well you can't bring that back
it's like give me a give me a break well
here
well for you know for obviously for the
kids listening this is how you can steal
anything
just so you know don't steal anything
you can't afford
this may be counter-intuitive to the
reason why you're stealing something
right
don't act suspicious okay kids dead
giveaway because they're watching your
body
because i've had friends i've had three
four five
friends that did security for stores
right i mean i had a
i had a friend who ran a conglomerate of
security for the source he used to sit
there all day
and their goal was to catch thieves
interesting and they studied their
language and their body language all
that stuff
and uh yeah i mean it's it's a real deal
so as soon as you you think you're
acting suspicious
you are the one time i ever got caught
shoplifting stealing and i
nothing really happened i went to i was
going to steal a pair of pants
i had tried on a pair of pants right and
then i was going to steal them
why why because because i was
17 years old or just because being an
idiot and i didn't have you know i just
wanted to steal these pair of pants
so i took the tags off and the reason
why i was gonna steal these specific
pair of pants because sometimes
they don't have that little white clip
thing on you know like that yeah the
thing that's that
that sounds like will go off they didn't
have that on those pants for whatever
reason was defect so i went to i was
stealing i was in the dressing room
putting on those pants i was going to
leave my
own put the pants on screen right in my
book bag and then while i was
i was like going to put them on there
was a pin
like a like a pin that somebody puts on
a blazer and a t-shirt
with the pin upright and i stepped on
the pin
so i was in the green i was in the
dressing room with the pin
fully lodged in the heel of my foot the
hell out of here screaming
that security guard came because my no
my mom wasn't there like i was with my
friends and i i had to
have a doctor i swear
i had to have a doctor come into the
dressing room or the nurse
at the mall whoever and remove the pin
and give me a tetanus shot right then
and there in my arm
and then i had to take off the pants and
i was gonna steal because obviously i
couldn't steal them now
right and and then walk away but that's
the only time i ever tried
shoplifting but they technically didn't
know i was stealing but i was stealing
and then i got i got the pin in the heel
did i ever tell you about the time i
stole base
i was accessory to stealing no at a
baseball card show
no i was sure we didn't speak about this
before and a baseball card showed you
so i'm what i'm maybe
sixth grade something like that sixth
grade and uh
in my neighborhood where i lived one of
those uh you know those posts they were
having a baseball card show
and i went with my my buddy and uh i was
wearing a fanny pack at the time they
were
involved and fanny packs are back by the
way i put a fanny pack on right they're
back in a big way if he is now as a
matter of fact
the perfect accessory to that outfit
yeah and then people really will know
that i am just a straight man
just like straight stuff yeah um i go in
and my and my friend is like oh this is
very lax here
and i don't remember what was said in
order to get us from a place of because
we weren't thieves
and we didn't it wasn't a habit you're
kids but we're in the moment
and i remember the cards so he's like
all of a sudden he lifts like a kirby
pocket rookie
kirby pocket kirby puck that's a rare
all right pumpkin
puck great player yeah got r.i.p curry
puckett died oh i thought he had
like blindness or something i didn't
know he died i i would i would 30
i would guarantee kirby puckett i think
her photography
he died in march of 2006. oh my god
yeah unfortunately he passed away he was
only 45 years old from a stroke he had
he had a stroke oh my god he's my age
yeah it was 10 years ago
oh well actually that was like 14 years
ago this he died around the time
you were stealing his rookie card yeah
well i guess i well i didn't take
anything from him i took
it that's not that's not i didn't take
anything from the pocket of state
everyone should know that
the pockets we know you're watching
great players i know they're watching
pockets
it wasn't personal um so i didn't take
the card
but i did have the fanny pack and it had
three zippers
one of them was on the inside it's very
discreet right and so he's like let me
put it in
the fanny right so i let him do it we go
to the next one
he takes the daryl he takes the dot good
and he takes roger clemens
these are all the rookie cards going in
my fanny okay all right so
no one's saying anything to us right if
you remember the way they used to do
baseball card shows was
they had just vendors set up their own
tables okay so it was just aisles and
aisles and eyes of different people
selling their cards right so we're
hopping and we're hopping and he's taken
and he's taken
and i guess it's it's that it's that big
is that it's not smaller than that but
it was
that busy almost like it's like a
warehouse it's a convention yeah and um
and no one say anything i'm like all
right i guess we're getting these cards
i was heavy into the cards and i was
like and we
go to leave my dad dropped us off and my
dad was coming to get us at a certain
time
okay and at that time we go out to the
front we go to leave the place to walk
out to the front
to go meet my dad and as we're going out
the front door two guys step in front of
it and they go you're not going anywhere
they knew we stole from the second we
stole right and they watched us steal
every single hall of fame baseball
players card one by one
and they thought i thought i was like
doing some spy [ __ ] and put it in my
fanny they knew they were all in there
right so they're like you're not going
anywhere am i like why are like you know
you took the cards i'm like what
and at that moment my dad comes walking
in the front
and he sees us and he goes what's going
on because they wouldn't let us out and
he goes
they stole cards and he goes what and he
goes your son stole cards and he goes
what do you mean he goes they're in his
fanny pack and my dad turns to me he
goes
is that true and i said uh
i didn't take any of them he did but
they are in my fanny pack
right and my dad only time my entire
life
he got so mad at me that he grabbed me
by my jacket and lifted me in the air
oh my god is this the person i've been
raising
and i swear to god right
i pissed myself in that moment i pissed
my pants
in that moment i pissed i urinated into
my pants in my pants
and my dad pulled me down that's an 11
year old i'm so sorry
and he what happened was he i don't
think even the guys who
ran the baseball card table knew that
that was going to happen and they were
like oh and they were like this is more
of a
this is even more of a we weren't even
going to go here like he's pissing
right so then i think they just let it
go like my dad was in such a fury
that he's like get outside and i just
left but i have all
to this day i have the car you still
have the car they were in my fanny and
when he did that the guys were just like
oh and then he just
i just i was upset and i peed and i ran
out
and so we left and i just have those
cards
and um we get back to the house and my
friend
gets dropped off we live we lived around
birth control number four
we lived around the corner from each
other right so my friend goes to his
house
my dad comes and says and my dad we were
in apartment buildings and my dad just
is like i don't believe this what would
make you do that
you know what's wrong i didn't raise
someone like this you gotta you have to
know what's
between rain road you have to set an
example you have a little sister
and he's screaming i mean i'm crying i'm
crying i'm crying right
and we had a sectional couch that kind
of rounded like that
yeah so it rounded so there was a space
in between the rounding of the sectional
couch
and the corner of the wall right so like
i was like
crying and i jumped in there and i was
just like sitting there
because i was like so upset and he was
like what are you doing i'm like nothing
and then my dad left the house
he came he comes back hours later and i
was crying in that spot
it was the day time when he left
nighttime when he came back so when he
came back none of the lights were on i
hadn't moved and i was still crying in
that same spot
the house was pitch black he opened the
apartment turned on lights and he's like
where are you
and he walked and i was in the same
exact spot and i saw a look come
over his face like oh my god i yelled
too much i was too
mad at him for this and he immediately
looked at me as like
i'm so sorry and he's like come out you
know from there and he sat me down he's
like
i didn't mean to get upset like that i'm
so sorry that you've been here this
whole time like you shouldn't have been
standing there you know and he starts
with me he's like you can't do this mind
you the entire time while the sun was
going down and i was
just crying in the house alone behind
the couch my friend
his family had a very different reaction
they were like don't be an idiot
and he was outside playing the whole day
i heard him doing endos and wheelies on
his bike he had a monster
all day he had a mongoose and he had
mushroom handles which i was always
very very uh i always loved i never got
mushroom handles do you ever see those
mushroom handles no
mushroom handles were really really they
were just so fun to grip
mushroom handles on a bike mushroom
handles on a bike yeah
it's so interesting oh yes i have seen
that yeah yeah yeah yeah
anyway those are called mushroom hands
yeah so he's out all day playing
and i'm i was doing that cry like that
eddie murphy talks about delirious
you were doing that so okay you fast
forward let's fast forward
two three years later okay we're at
sears and roebuck okay it's the holidays
yeah okay wrestling lgn figures were
huge
right i used to collect them the
restless like the wwf and
me and my dad are walking around sears
and i told if i told the story another
podcast i apologize but
you know god bless us all uh and i'm
walking right now and this is jesse the
body ventura ljn wrestling senator jesse
everybody's in the center that's right
also from minnesota yeah
i never made that connection i pissed my
pants getting scolded
stealing the kirby pocket rook rookie
he's from minnesota where do you hear
what happens now
okay watch what happens minnesota
connection yeah it's like bobby's world
that's the one he was like this he's got
the pink trunks on which is doug
and hey by the way right so my dad's
like yeah you can get it i was like you
know can i get this
yeah you can get it you know on the way
out we'll get it so i'm holding it so
we're walking around and
sears is a mad house of course
so this just it's christmas time and he
he can't find what he needs
and the places to do and we're going to
leave and he doesn't get what he needs
but i still have the figure
so we get online and we're waiting
online and the line is not moving if
you've ever been to see us
shout out see us i think they closed
though is here still a business
it's unclear is it it's unclear sears
bankrupt
yeah yeah they went bankrupt in 2012. so
your survival is in doubt that was from
may 2012 okay
might still be open sears could be
hanging on sears was
mayhem and they don't have top-notch
personnel there
at least they didn't you know when i was
there in 1987
it just was a zoo okay this show is
sponsored by jcpenney there's no cell
phones
there's none of that right so we got to
get home yeah so we're waiting online
and we're online for like no joke maybe
20 minutes and the line is not moved
people are fighting
right really people are fighting because
everyone's just frustrated
and my dad is like i i look at him and
he goes you know we gotta get home
you know you know mommy doesn't know
where we are right now we gotta get home
and he goes uh you know let me go look
let's go look for that thing again
and we go look and as we're walking he's
like let me see the wrestler
and we're walking around the store and
god bless shout out dad
best dad apple cider vinegar he pops
open the plastic
yeah and he open takes jesse the body
out of the packaging
and now he's holding jesse the body and
he puts down the packaging and now he's
just holding the rubber figurine
and we're walking around we're gonna go
i don't see it he goes all right let's
uh
let's go home and we start walking and
i'm like what are we doing exactly and
we walk around the register we walk to
the glass doors
and he pushes the glass door open and he
has it like in his hand
and we just walk out the glass doors and
i'm like what the
hell is going on yeah and
and we're in the parking lot we haven't
arrived at the car yet and i go dad
what are you doing and he goes i
he goes we haven't moved in 20 minutes i
know you want this we got to get home
i promise you i'll come back this week
and i'll pay for it
and i was like well how the hell are you
going to do that and he's like i'll just
come back
and i'll pay for it i'll tell him i'll
and i go
no i'm not leaving i swear to god he was
like wanna go i'm not leaving
i go it's not right to steal you taught
me that yourself i think
what are we doing here we have to go
back in we have to wait we have to pay
for it
wow i swear to god i took a stand and i
lifted him up and he started pissing
i said i'm not i'm not gonna do it and
he goes
you're right we walked back in walked
back got the plastic put him back in
stood online for like another half hour
paid for it and we left worried your
mother's sick
that's it she didn't know where he was
she thought i got taken by a van driving
around neighborhood
the differences between your father and
my father
are so insane because first of all
number one the initial story
of you doing that putting the
putting the thing in your fanny pack and
then telling
your dad that it was your friend my
father would have punched my father
would have the same
would have held me up and i would piss
her pants and he said you're ratting on
your friends and you got a fanny pack
he would have shook me that's been a
number one and then number two
two years later if i would have stood
outside to my father and said that exact
thing where i said my dad would have
been like
i raised a gay son and then thrown me
into the back of my car
to back of his car and been like i can't
believe you want to steal a figurine and
then she he probably
went home but he would have looked at
the figurine like what is going on he's
in pink tights
i guarantee you my dad would have went
home dropped me off my mother's house
and said good job linda made him gay
and then explained to him that all i did
was the right thing right yeah
that's so funny but there you go i mean
yeah and i and i i haven't stole
stolen anything since then yeah i don't
i i i now
am at a point now where even if i could
for example it's very easy now to steal
at the self
checkout in the supermarket yeah if i
don't i don't
think though that's tempting that
they're extra watching that they aren't
but
i just want there's been a couple times
where i've had i've had yogurts in my
bag that didn't scan
and i just would call the lady over and
say hey two of these didn't scam okay if
i'm gonna be fully honest you just
reminded me of something and if we're
gonna do full disclosure yeah we're
gonna do full disclosure
sometimes i mean maybe
twice like and i'm talking twice at any
time right i think
maybe one or two times i do that i did
that thing where i
realized last second that like a 12 can
sleeve of seltzer was on the bottom okay
and everything was paid for and i was
like about to walk out and
i was like oh frick i forgot and then
instead of going back and going online
i just get 12 free cans of salsa yeah
you know but and kind of in a way though
in a way if i'm being honest with you
i feel because of what supermarkets have
the balls and it is balls to do this
to make us check out our own groceries
and not give us a discount at all for
doing so
you deserve twelve free cans of salt so
you're actually in my opinion
you're absolutely i'm okay with the
self-checkout but i can't pay the same
price this wasn't itself
it wasn't itself so so then so then for
me for me
not only do you get free 12 free cans of
cell phone supermarket
the cash-ish has to pay the 2.99 for
themselves
new thing which self-checkout it's for
companies to so they don't have to hire
i know cashiers it's ridiculous like
what are we talking about here
it's like it's ridiculous because it's
like wha why i should get a discount on
the groceries i don't work at the
grocery store
it's like bill burr has the whole
billboard has a whole bit he's like i
pay a hundred percent of the money
to make 100 of the sandwich yeah
it's and it's a good point nation of
shoplifters the rise of supermarket
sells
checkout scam of course it's
self-checkout scams it is so now
more people are stealing because why
wouldn't they i mean what am i gonna do
australia and new zealand seem to be the
only one the creepy solution
supermarkets are using the stop theft at
self-service checkouts
digital faces what is this who is that
they're having like digital faces at the
self-checkout because it
creeps people out like watching feels
that a digital face is
watching you people are less likely to
steal it says that's
insane because do they think that
someone is watching like behind a camera
but that stuff works it's just a digital
image
dude wow but she looks real that's by
the way that looks like victoria beckham
it might be victoria beckham's is that
not victoria beckham i think it's
victoria beckham
in scotland conducted pull up a picture
of victoria beckham
and the picture of this woman that's
victoria beckham
is that not i mean that is literally her
yeah it's victoria it looks like he
looks
like her twin that's victoria beckham
wow you could style your hair like that
right now
like you could you you could be victoria
beckham in a in a snap
yeah i don't know it looks great dude it
did that's so stupid that's like
you remember those remember that cars
that's david beckham
you know i thought he was like blonde
you know what's interesting about david
beckham because he's obviously so
handsome so rich such a phenomenal
athlete
if you ever heard david beckham talk his
voice
it sounds so dumb because the universe
is balanced his
he's like hi i'm david beckham it's like
such a high pitch
because he just got everything out yeah
listen to david beckham's voice
yeah watch this will be the only
interview where he talks deeper but he's
got his
as a as an owner and also
[Laughter]
oh my god it's so high-pitched it's so
hard did you ever see that video
do you ever see that i take that in a
second oh that's what i said i take
out i'll talk like mickey mouse if i
could look like a thousand percent
you know what that stuff the supermarket
reminded me of the supermarket uh thing
reminded me of too
remember that car security system viper
where it was just an
image of a snake of a rattlesnake in
your back seat and
it would deter car thefts no put them in
viper security the club is the
anti-theft determiner no put up viper
security system it was literally a
hologram of a snake
stop it go to the commercial viper
security system commercials
okay what do you mean commercial snake
come on dude yes commercials unless it
was just a commercial and i thought
yeah this look at this look at it look
at this this is unless i
[Laughter]
i thought this whole time that that's
got to be a metaphor
dude it's just a metaphor
wait so the security system wasn't a
hologram of the actual
rattlesnake i think the commercial used
cg viper to tell you
that this is the kind of protection
you're going to get it would be like a
viper
now as a kid i understand what you mean
because when i used to listen to my
grandpa
um when i lived with him he used to
listen to 10 10 wins
22 minutes i remember the day i was
walking around as an adult
that that clicked in my head and i
finally understood what that meant
listening for 22 minutes we'll give you
all the coverage
right i that did not click with me until
i was
uh so what did you think they would give
you you didn't know i
i was like what like what are they
saying
i i just didn't know i was like like
like if we listen this whole time like
we win something like i truly didn't
know i
just didn't understand i couldn't take
the leap yeah
google google if you can i don't know if
you ever seen this video on youtube
like it i forgot what country it is
where it's like man with high pitched
voice tv host laughs at him
um high-pitched voice tv tv host laughs
at him
or yet laughs at him something like that
yes yes yes this boomerang talk show
have you ever seen this
oh my god this is six minutes long no
but let's
it's another language okay
yeah okay yeah go go here
okay here we go here we go here here
this is real watch us just keep on
okay yeah say it's there
look at those
[Music]
yeah this is him now it's cutting back
where yeah go back to here we go
me
yeah don't fast yeah keep going keep
going because because
then he takes a question hold up this is
crazy
could you imagine because i've been in
well you can't stop laughing like
and you're saying you're sorry and
whatever you're playing so hard
yeah he knows he knows the second he
opens his mouth it's over it's gonna be
hard
he's gonna bite because this woman's in
a neck brace
so she i wish i knew what the subtitles
were what can you do
but yeah it keeps going
[Music]
to leave
is in the whole life there's one girl
laughing a little bit
excuse me i think he takes and then he
takes a question
yeah yeah go to where he takes the
question
oh yeah here we go here we go here we go
no go back go back
yeah cause they're looking man
why is that guy's voice
[Music]
why is no one else laughing
[Laughter]
this is real i don't it can't be real
right
it's called boomerang talk show
well his laughs are real no one else is
left he got fired for this i know he
says
wow look people walk out
i wonder if they're on because they're
talking about that that this is
something they live with yes so that's
the actual topic
it's about voices like that yeah yeah
can you scroll through the comments and
see if that's real or not or
what does it say i don't know about
anyone else but they only laugh so hard
because the hosts laugh
sounds so funny okay
i was crying when the man with the low
voice talked oh my god
you lost your job because an internet
sensation is a result i hope
oh okay i see okay
holy so he did lose his job that's true
well listen
if we can't put the video up go to just
google boomerang talk show
guy laughs at man with high voice and
follow along it's one of the funniest
videos
it would make me laugh hard there's been
times on the show
so one time we had to do this thing
where we we
we tried to do we try to do things
differently so one time we're like what
if all four of us were out there at the
same time like not in the back but all
on stage
right so we did that we organized this
thing where we played
professionals in quantum physics okay
and we had a moderator like a real
moderator and we were on a panel with
other people that knew what they were
talking about too
and then the four of us and we did it
like at a at a theater in manhattan
and we filled the theater up and um
we had to start each talking about and
they we he had questions to ask us that
we had to answer to the best of our
abilities right in front of this crowd
and gatto i
i couldn't i couldn't stop crying
laughing so we just even
changed it to make it hinge in the
moment we're just like
just keep asking questions we'll make
this a punishment for him right because
i
could not speak and they were asking him
about
sopa and pippa something was quite one
q was a quantum physics person joe was
talking about soap and
i think it had to do with um what's sopa
and pippa i think there was like
laws about um uh yeah
by the way pippa is an is a is a pretty
common name
for a girl there's people in this world
named pippa like it's about like
security yeah stop online piracy act is
sopa and protect ip act as pippa
so joe had to talk about so and the guy
was
you might be able to find it i don't
know what we called it it was the joe
gatto punishment so
oh there oh cause it's not a house okay
so it's so funny they would rip that
down and
you're part of the show i'm the one who
has to sign off if we have the rights to
it um
the guy was like so what do you like in
the middle of a few questions in a row
he's like so what's your take on like
soap and peppa and joko
yeah soap and pippa i'm fine with him
he didn't even know what they meant what
they meant
shaking bright purple because
when you're trying to bs in the moment
like when because when
you're not allowed to laugh is like
church or whatever like this situation
with this guy
it's when you left the hardest that
thing happened to me
yeah on the stage dude where i was are
you talking about me laughing and
almost getting blacking out yeah i was a
second one you almost went unconsciously
yeah well yeah that's like that's like
in grammar school like
the funniest things would be like if the
kids slipped the fart past the teacher
or did something what funny when the
teacher wasn't looking and then when
they turned around
and you had to hold in the laugh it was
impossible it was impossible for me do
you remember those little things and hey
babe this but remember those little key
chains and things that we
pushed in you'll be like [ __ ]
i had them on my keychain and i was in
religion class
right and you know what i was i'm like a
teacher's talking
and uh and it was miss fiducia yeah
and uh i'm like she turned around like
and i would say what an idiot i am right
but yeah
i'm a kid i'm a teen and i go um eat
[ __ ]
right and she was she was turning around
she was like because it was like that
couldn't have been someone you sound
like a robot anyway yeah so she's
turning
[ __ ] and she's like what who did that
who did it and she like walked down the
aisles and she was like oh get it
and everyone's like and she turns she
turns around she goes
back and i'm like hey she turned out she
goes
and she just starts screaming right and
then i think she sees
she she may have she may i don't
remember if she caught me
or not but i think she did because i
thought she really had it out for me
after that
right because i got a hundred
on every test in her grade that year
right and then she
she offered extra credit and i did the
extra credit
my average was supposed to be like 102
in her class
right and when i got my report card it
was like a 98
and i went to her and i was like miss
feducia i have gotten a hundred
right on every single oh i walked in
class actually i walked up and i said
can i just talk to you for a moment at
the desk right and i said i just i see
that you gave me a 98 but like we had
five
five tests this year i got 100 on
everyone and right that huge extra
credit report
right and you said and whoever did that
would get two points so i should have
102 average
yeah 98 average yeah and she's like yes
that's right
and i was like well like how do like why
would you do that and she says
she goes then she starts hearing me and
she goes yeah that's right and then
in front of everyone else she gets up
she goes right in my face and she goes
only god is perfect
and i was like i don't know about that
why did you make me do the extra
credit you knew i got 100 on every test
you should have told me
hey back it up a notch because not only
you're not getting 100 to get 98
don't take a day to do the extra credit
i'm going to save you time she let me do
it right and i was like why would you
make me do the extra credit i had 100
average already like you wasted my time
and she goes sit down you're acting
like a genuine ass a genuine
ass she said she was in my
face she screamed it and i was like okay
and i just went and sat down again
because she knew i was the guy that was
she knew where the guy is
she knew you were the guy yeah she knew
she lived with a guy
yeah dude i mean catholic school it's
just you know
i i i their stories i mean you know
we're almost at an hour in the episode
i could do let's do catholic school
stories next episode let's do it
i have i have so much i have so many
catholic school stories yeah and none of
them involve being
by priests that's it babe yeah what can
you do all right that was it hey baypod
subscribe on youtube youtube.com no
pressure network
there you go follow us on all socials
you can find the podcast every thursday
it comes out on everywhere you get
podcasts
uh yeah that's what else what else
i mean listen i got some stand up dates
coming up uh
christy comedy.com check it out i'm
becoming a city near you
and uh and yeah no please hit the
subscribe and like button
uh text me 718-260-6619 that's my
community app
and uh i get your text and i can text
you back and stuff it's a cool thing i'm
trying out i'm going to tell you a story
about that eventually
beautiful hey babe hey pip
hey babe hey babe
hey babe